[Música]
hola muy buenas tardes como están
bueno pensemos en eso exactamente la
única forma de cambiar al mundo es
cambiando la idea dominante de cada
quien
las ideas que habitan en nuestra mente
determinan nuestras acciones y por lo
tanto nuestros resultados si o no
básicamente todos actuamos según la idea
dominante que habita en nuestra mente
sobre algo por ejemplo digamos que la
idea dominante que tiene sobre los gatos
negros es que traen mala suerte qué pasa
si te encuentras un gato negro te alejas
del verdad y te da mala suerte pero si
por el contrario la idea dominante que
tienes es que los gatos negros fueron
muy de malas porque aparecieron en una
en una historieta al lado de una bruja y
la gente ya dijo que eran de mala suerte
entonces que no que al contrario son muy
bonitos se te aparece un gato negro y
qué sucede te acercas a él verdad bueno
mira como dos ideas dominantes sobre un
mismo tema generando reacciones
exactamente opuestas visto qué pasaría
si les dijera que haciendo el estudio
para escribir mi libro más famoso
encontré una serie de ideas dominantes
que habitan en la mente del latino y que
básicamente nos tienen jodidos
y que tenemos que cambiarlas lo más
pronto posible el cambio de estas ideas
dominantes creó un éxito en mi vida
impresionante una abundancia
impresionante y realmente espero que
traigan ese mismo efecto en ti listo
luego lo denomina en las cuatro cumbres
porque a las cuatro cumbres porque
tienen características muy similares
para lograr cada uno de esos cambios en
las en estas ideas dominantes vas a
tener que trabajar mucho va a tener que
cambiar muchísimas cosas pero sobre todo
vas a necesitar mucho esfuerzo sostenido
entonces estoy en las cuatro cumbres de
hoy la primera cumbre que tienes que
ascender lo primero que tienes que
conquistar para modificar tu vida de
ahora en adelante es esta el
autoconocimiento dinámico que pasó
durante una cantidad de tiempo te
dijeron que para ser bueno en lo que sea
que quieras listo como quieras lo que
sea que quieras tenías que iniciar por
el autoconocimiento eso pues están muy
bien verdad pero la gente empezó a decir
yo me conozco y a mí el inglés no me
entra
desde pequeñito soy negado serrado y
trancaron pregúntenle a mi papá mira yo
me conozco y a mí el inglés no me entra
yo me conozco y no me gustan los cursos
virtuales yo me conozco y no me gustan
las ventas yo me conozco y no me gusta
hablar en público
cuál es el denominador común de todo eso
el autoconocimiento tienes un problema
crónico de autoconocimiento
yo lo llamo el autoconocimiento caga
tivo
mira cómo funciona si tú dices yo me
conozco y para eso soy malo y te sirve
el autoconocimiento no no porque te
estás privando de algo pero si tú dices
yo me conozco y por eso soy bueno hay
que sirve el autoconocimiento no tampoco
porque encontramos que la gente se
dedica a hacer eso para lo que se creó
se sabe buena siendo que puede ser bueno
para muchas otras cosas pero a mí se me
quieto que yo soy buenos para esto o sea
todo la esencia de la oposición al
cambio radica en tu autoconocimiento
demos un paso más arriba es la
incidencia personal hablemos de la
incidencia corporativa hablemos del
autoconocimiento corporativo digamos
tomemos para el ejemplo una área que sea
transversal todas las organizaciones
listo algo así como sistemas o
contabilidad el área de contabilidad tu
empresa qué pasa cuando una persona de
tu empresa un compañero suyo le dice a
otro bueno y por qué no llamas a los de
contabilidad y esa persona contesta para
que si ella nunca contestan
qué pasa con el intento de llamada
óyeme y por qué no hablas con juan para
que ese índice que no a todo entonces de
anamaría gnosis el agua el ojo de gema
me deja de hablar tres días en este
español del ingeniero pero para que ese
ingeniero dice que cierto y nunca sé
nada
el problema en las organizaciones es un
exceso de autoconocimiento aterrador
entonces abre tu corazón porque te voy a
explicar el autoconocimiento de dónde
salió todo autoconocimiento verdad
hablemos del inglés
el inglés te metiste a estudiar inglés
te saliste echen la culpa lo que quieras
te volviste a meter a estudiar inglés te
saliste echa la culpa lo que quieras a
partir de ahí dijiste yo me conozco y a
mí el inglés no me entra el problema fue
que confundiste una o dos malas
experiencias con autoconocimiento y el
latino fue educado para darle un poder
impresionante a la palabra
autoconocimiento una vez que tú metes
algo dentro de toda tu conocimiento
hasta ahí fue la primera cumbre si
quieres hacer que grandes cosas sucedan
en tu vida desconfía totalmente de tu
autoconocimiento recibe esto el
autoconocimiento es una simple versión
que haces sobre tu pasado para
justificar algo en tu presente la
próxima vez que digas yo me conozco en
inglés no me entra piensan esto que tan
de malas hay que ser en la vida para
ganarse el único cerebro del mundo al
que no le entra en inglés
no hay que estar muy
listo entonces si tu excusa para no
estudiar inglés o por no hacer un curso
virtual es que te conoces lo sentimos
mucho no se sostiene la siguiente gran
cumbre que tienes que contestar la
siguiente gran idea dominante que tienes
que cambiar
tienes que aprender a aprender a través
del sistema de éxito no a través del
sistema de errores y nate o mucho
corazón aquí
toda la vida te dijeron frases como
echando a perder
se aprende rompiendo se aprende que el
error que comete el error bueno nos
volvimos terroristas
estamos aprendiendo en la forma más
costosa que hay que es por intermedio
del error es una forma de aprender pero
en la forma más costosa que hay de
aprender
la frase está mal te voy a cambiar tu
idea dominante mira hasta el momento
dijiste echando a perder se aprende
verdad pero es que la característica
inevitable el error no es que se aprende
la característica inevitable el error es
que se pierde
la frase debe ser echando a perder se
pierde ojalá y se aprenda mira te voy a
dar te voy a dar ejemplos digamos que ya
te picó el bichito el empresarismo del
emprendimiento listo entonces va a
montar un negocio propio montas un
restaurante feliz contratas personas un
día llegas a tu restaurante verdad y uno
de sus empleados te dice un jefe
imagínense que se nos olvidó revisar las
puertas que estuvieran bien cerradas y
se dañó el producto pero aprendimos que
hay que revisarlas todas las noches
no invaluable tu conocimiento
mira es como aprender por intermedio del
error puede que llegue verdad al éxito
pero vas a caminar por un camino de pues
vayas te vas a llegar demasiado
maltratado es como intentar ser una
torta sin leer las instrucciones
entonces dice listo yo hace es la mejor
trata del mundo mal ver empresario a
tener una panadería y voy a vender la
mejor torta del mundo te pones a hacer
la torta no lee las instrucciones y
entonces le va a echar 10 huevos porque
es que el huevo es del huevo es el huevo
papá y le echa 10 huevos puede que a una
tortilla entonces después va ahí no toca
comprar otra vez todos los materiales
para volver a hacer la torta verdad
entonces alguien te dice no le eche
mucha noche mucha mantequilla porque a
la gente le gusta la mantilla y bueno
turno y tinte queda quemada que pasa la
tercera vez que dices tengo que comprar
los materiales para comprar para hacer
la torta
señores aprender por intermedio del
error es el harakiri del empresario de
hoy
puede que vuelvas a empezar verdad pero
en muy lastimado ahora ojo no es que
seamos perfectos y no cometamos errores
no hay una metodología de ahora en
adelante cuando haya una reunión para un
proyecto lo que sea que tengas debe
haber esta pregunta
ah qué error nos estamos arriesgando
yo lo hice con mi equipo visto aquí nos
estamos arriesgando cuál es el producto
más importante de la empresa la
conferencia de luis miguel visto a
hierro nos estamos arriesgando que está
que los de miguel lleguen la conferencia
donde la lleva en su computadora que
tarde se la roben o qué tal que se le
dañe que tanto llega a realizar una
conferencia a decirles ay qué pena
contigo es que imagínate que los vídeos
y tono porque es que me roban yo no
tengo la culpa la culpa
me vuelves a contratar no pues resulta
que no me dejan salir sin una usb
amarrada a mi esta usb tiene la
presentación para que yo llegue sin la
presentación me tienen que robar los
pantalones van
listo y pues qué crees que crees ha
sucedido dos veces y el cliente nunca se
ha enterado de que me robaron o se me
dañó el pc pero mira el mundo no puede
seguir aprendiendo por el sistema de
errores porque vamos a prohibir el
consumo de plástico de un solo uso
porque el océano está lleno de plástico
porque dijimos que ya no podemos emitir
más gases porque nos vamos a tostar
todos el mundo ha prendido por medio del
sistema de error es la forma más costosa
de aprender ahora aprendes a través del
sistema de éxito la tercera cumbre la
tercera cumbre que vas a subir tú sales
de aquí ya rallado rallado entonces
buscas a tu hijo y le dices mi amor
puesto en inglés en inglés porque yo
siempre dije que yo me conozco y el
problema no es de autoconocimiento sino
de esfuerzo sostenido voy a aprender
inglés verdad entonces tú y yo te dice y
por qué mamá porque papá tú le respondes
porque nunca es demasiado tarde si o no
mi amor es que nunca es demasiado
temprano
qué pasa si el niño escucha que nunca es
demasiado tarde
si nunca es demasiado tarde cuál es el
problema
es más por qué crees que se nos hace
tarde todos vivimos convencidos de que
nunca es demasiado tarde entonces para
que le hacemos listo y es que esas
fueron ideas que habitaron en tu mente
que nadie nunca se había atrevido a
decir no son verdad están mal hay que
mandarlas a recoger hay que cuestionar
esas ideas dominantes y la cuarta la
cuarta cumbre que vas a subir la más
hermosa que te tienes que llevar hoy
es hora de que te enteres y tu hijo se
entere
que vives en un mundo que ya no necesita
que creas en ti
las cosas están tan bien hechas todo
está tan bien hecho todo funciona todo
está a una distancia de tus dedos todo
está listo para ti que funciona aunque
no creas en ti cuál fue el problema los
motivadores que te vendieron la idea la
idea dominante de creer en ti como el
requisito para meterte en algo y resulta
que no es el requisito es la
consecuencia
mira yo me metía estoy mi papá mi papá
mi cascada cuatro veces al año las
cuatro entregas de notas
y siempre habilite inglés y matemáticas
detestaba el inglés me metí a estudiar
en inglés bruto negado serrado trancado
detestan dolo pero con esfuerzo
sostenido dos horas al día durante un
año cuando empecé a estudiar inglés yo
era instructor de aeróbicos me ganaba
cinco mil pesos no me ganaba 15 mil
pesos la hora
dictaba tres horas por la mañana tres
horas por la tarde y me sentía muy bien
pago verdad aprendí inglés contra todos
los pronósticos
me volví profesor de inglés empecé a
ganarme 50 mil pesos la hora
dictaba tres zonas por la mañana tres
horas por la tarde y empecé a decir a
partir de ahí guau
yo nací fue para dictar inglés
veis mira
tuve la fortuna de conocer a sus grandes
escaladores dijeron que si no para el
himalaya yo que yo quiero ir yo quiero
ir que se necesita pregunte dijeron
cuerpo yo cuerpo no tengo parti cortico
que otra cosa mente de escalador
no conozco la nieve como actualmente es
calor de tiempo para entrenar no trabajo
de 7 a 7 no no no no ser deportista pues
sí pero tampoco a ese nivel no tanto y
una suma muy importante de dinero para
una experiencia de un mes en el himalaya
con cero posibilidades de éxito en la
que te puedes matar
un momento no tengo ni mente ni cuerpo
ni tiempo ni plata y ahora tengo mis
ganas de ir a la montaña
terminamos haciendo un récord mundial 16
cumbres en una misma temporada mira cuál
es el problema en la gente la gente está
buscando oportunidades verdad pero
espera que esa oportunidad esté hecha
maiden y resulta que en las miles y
millones de oportunidades que hay afuera
para ti las que están hechas para ti son
muy poquitas pero ese no es el único
problema el problema más grande es que
eres increíblemente parecido a una gran
cantidad de gente entonces adivina que
esa oportunidad que parece que está
hecha para ti qué crees le sirva una
gran cantidad de gente
si yo empecé me dijeron que no servía
para la música desde pequeñito me
dijeron tiene más oído una rodilla que
usted yo no nunca nunca quise inclusive
pero me picó el bichito en la música
será que no puede prender música bueno
empecé por la guitarra bien estuvo
chévere pase al bajo me gustó el bajo
porque el bajo vibra después mentira que
me bajo estaba dañado por eso vibraba
pero bueno me bajo vibra nos quedamos
sin batería estarme una banda de rock
nos quedamos sin baterista y mis
compañeros dijeron oiga luismi ustedes
de que enseña y que eso del esfuerzo
sostenido porque no lo aplica y aprende
la batería
y yo no estos manes me quieren es sacar
de la banda o una madre bueno yo soy el
baterista de afuera y realmente no es
qué tal si hubiera tenido que creer en
mí como escritor como alpinista como
músico como empresario y como
conferencista eres libre a partir de
este momento eres libre puedes meterte
en lo que quieras creer en ti ese es el
resultado no el requisito enseña solo tu
hijo por favor y la próxima década va a
ser fantástica valió la pena muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]